problema 61 dice el punto menos 32 yace
en la circunferencia cuya ecuación es x
más 3 al cuadrado más ye más un al
cuadrado igual a r al cuadrado cuál de
los siguientes debe ser el radio de la
circunferencia ok si nos dicen que este
punto está en la circunferencia dada por
esta ecuación quiere decir que si
ponemos las coordenadas de este punto
aquí entonces se da la igualdad bueno
vamos a ver qué nos dice esa igualdad
voy a poner x igual a menos 3 entonces
nos quedaría menos 3 + 3 al cuadrado más
y ya igualados entonces nos quedaría más
2 más 1 al cuadrado igual a r al
cuadrado
bueno esto de aquí que nos dice menos
330 este de aquí es 0 2 más 1 es 33 al
cuadrado es igual a r al cuadrado
entonces r al cuadrado es 9 y por lo
tanto r&r es igual a 3 vale entonces el
radio de la circunferencia sería igual a
3 entonces esa idea es importante si
tenemos una ecuación que define una
figura y nos dicen que un punto está en
esa figura entonces quiere decir que
las coordenadas del punto satisfacen la
igualdad de la ecuación bueno vamos al
problema 62 dice en la figura de abajo
si seno de x es igual a 5 entre 13
cuántos son coseno y tangente de x ok
trigonometría en trigonometría es bueno
acordarse de lo siguiente esta es una
mnemotecnia bueno una forma de acordarse
de seno coseno y tangente y se llama
soca tohá se escribe
toa toa toa si te memoriza sexto puedes
saber que quiere decirse no posee ni
tangente por ejemplo lo que quiere decir
eso es que seno de un ángulo digamos x
es igual al cateto opuesto entre la
hipotenusa de manera similar acá quiere
decir que el cose no es igual al cateto
adyacente entre la hipotenusa el coseno
de un ángulo x digamos y tangente de x
se produce a partir de la tercera que es
el opuesto entre la adyacente entonces
esto es para memorizar se las
definiciones de las funciones
trigonométricas vale bueno vamos a
ponerle nombres a esta figura de acá
para poder trabajar entonces pensemos
bueno aquí está el ángulo x entonces a
éste le vamos a llamar el opuesto a éste
el adyacente y esto de acá que es el
lado opuesto al ángulo recto es la
hipotenusa la hipotenusa vale y nos dan
el valor de seno de x ósea de acuerdo
con con sow nos están dando que o entre
h
es igual a 5 entre 13 ahora eso no
quiere decir que sea así
y hs a 13 por ejemplo podría ser 50 y h
130 y se da esta igualdad o tal vez es 1
y h3c quintos y también se da lo único
que sabemos es la razón entre estos dos
pero ahorita para hacer las cuentas si
podemos asumir que este lado mide 5 y
que este lado mide 13 de hecho justo ese
es el chiste de la trigonometría que
solo nos importan las razones vale bueno
entonces pensemos que este 5 y este es
13 y lo que nos piden es coseno y
tangente entonces coseno de x
jose no de x es igual a adyacente entre
hipotenusa osea a 5
no es cierto aa aaa entre 13 entonces
necesitamos encontrar a bueno pues a es
el tercer lado de este triángulo
rectángulo así que podemos aplicar el
teorema de pitágoras tenemos que a
cuadrado más 5 al cuadrado es igual a 13
al cuadrado la hipotenusa al cuadrado
entonces a cuadrada más 25 es igual a
169 restando 25 de ambos lados al
cuadrado es igual a 144 y por lo tanto a
es igual
12 porque es positivo entonces tenemos
que a es igual a 12 listo y con esto ya
tenemos todo lo necesario para calcular
las funciones trigonométricas que
queremos tenemos que coseno dx es igual
a entre 13 o sea es igual a 12 entre 13
y finalmente tangente de x tangente de x
esto a es igual a opuesto entre
adyacente que es igual a 5 entre 12 a 5
entre 12 entonces coseno de x es 12
entre 13 ok entonces es esta o esta y
tangente dxe5 entre 12 entonces la
respuesta es
muy bien vamos aquí abajo otro de
trigonometría dice en la siguiente
figura tenemos que seno de a es igual a
0.70 seno es sol entonces es seno
seno de a este ángulo es el ángulo a es
igual a opuesto entre hipotenusa si
porque es sol son ok pero nos están
diciendo que seno de an es igual a 0.7
0.7 y además tenemos más información
verdad tenemos la medida tenemos la
medida del ángulo opuesto y el del lado
opuesto que es 21 entonces tenemos que
21 / h es igual a 0.7 vamos a ver que
nos preguntan dice cuál es la longitud
de ac a pues hace justo es esta
hipotenusa de acá va entonces entonces
lo que queremos determinar es el valor
de esta h vamos a multiplicar por h de
ambos lados y dividir entre 0.7 tenemos
que h es igual a 21 entre 0.7 21 entre
73 entonces 21 entre 0.7 es igual a 30
la medida de h ósea del segmento ac es
igual a 30 opción c
problema 64 más trigonometría al parecer
quieren que aprendamos mucha
trigonometría bueno eso está bien eso
está bien dice aproximadamente cuántos
pies de altura tiene la lámpara aquí
está la lámpara que dice que mide h
nos dan este ángulo de acá a 40 grados
nos dan la medida del cateto adyacente
en pies y entonces tenemos que encontrar
alguna función trigonométricas que nos
relacione el cateto adyacente con el
opuesto otra vez zocato a eso
toma entonces tangente es la que
relaciona cateto opuesto con adyacente y
vale bueno entonces tenemos que tangente
tangente de 40 grados es igual al cateto
opuesto o sea h entre el adyacente o sea
20 va queremos determinar h entonces
pasamos el 20 multiplicando voy a
voltear la igualdad nos queda que h es
igual a 20 por tangente de 40 grados
como lo vamos a hacer con tangente de 40
grados a mira aquí abajo nos dan nos dan
esta información nos dicen que podemos
usar que tangente de 40 grados es
aproximadamente 0.84 entonces h es
aproximadamente 20 x 0.80 y 420 x 0.84 y
esto es igual a cuanto 2 por 8 de 16 2
por 4 es 8 entonces esto es 16
punto 8 16.8 pies se va problema
problema 65 dice el triángulo rectángulo
abc se muestra a continuación ahí
tenemos el triángulo rectángulo abc dice
que ecuación da el valor correcto
de bs de bs bueno pues vamos a ver qué
opciones nos dan para ver pues o sea si
son correctas o no dice senos de 32
grados es igual a veces entre 8.2 seno
de 32 grados toca toda otra vez o acá
entonces seno de 32 grados es igual
abc a ver si es opuesto entre hipotenusa
entonces es igual a veces eso está bien
entre hipotenusa 8.2 8.29 la hipotenusa
la hipotenusa es 10.6 entonces no está
esta igualdad está mal a ver b coseno de
32 grados es igual a bs entre 10.6
coseno de 32 coseno es adyacente entre
hipotenusa entonces coseno es 8.2 entre
10.6 no coseno no tiene nada que ver con
veces entonces ésta está mal verdad va
entonces cosenos 8.2 entre 10.6 entonces
ésta está no es se tangente de 58 grados
esto se ve interesante como que quieren
que usemos este ángulo de acá verdad
como este es de 90 y estos 32 estos dos
tienen que ser complementos para que
todos sumen 180 entonces este mide 58
grados y entonces ahora tenemos que
hacer las funciones trigonométricas pero
desde el punto de vista debe entonces
ahora el adyacentes este acá y el
opuesto es aquel y la hipotenusa sigue
siendo ave bueno vamos a ver que dice
estar acá tangente de 58 grados es igual
a 8.2 bajada tangente es el opuesto
entre veces entre veces a éste hay que
dividir entre el adyacente entonces el
efecto tangente es de 58 grados 58
grados es igual al opuesto de 58 grados
o sea 8.2 dividido entre el adyacente
que es vece bc y eso es justo lo que
dice el inciso c entonces esta opción es
correcta y finalmente el de dice seno de
58 grados es igual abc abc pues no
verdad porque ese no empieza con el
cateto opuesto y aquí nos están poniendo
veces arriba en el numerador pero eso
eso no se vale necesitamos
para que de veras sea el seno de 58
grados entonces ésta también es
incorrecta y por lo tanto la respuesta
es
bueno le dejamos hasta aquí nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo